[Musique]
je m'appelle vincent sempastous je suis
docteur en droit de l'université
toulouse i capitole et le 2 décembre
2020 j'ai soutenu sous la direction du
professeur vincent dussart une thèse
consacrée à la péréquation financière en
droit des collectivités territoriales la
notion de péréquation financière n'est
pas une notion qui est propre au droit
des collectivités territoriales de
manière générale elle renvoie à une
technique de répartition financière
équitable seulement appliquer un droit
spécifique et à des sujets de droit
particulier il convient de définir les
contours de cette notion est
d'identifier des implications de son
application dans un état unitaire
décentralisé
la première partie de ma thèse consiste
donc à démontrer que la péréquation
financière est une redistribution des
ressources destiné à doter chaque
collectivité territoriale d'une capacité
de s'administrer librement la
péréquation financière apparaît ainsi
comme un instrument essentiel de la
décentralisation et de la cohésion de
territoriale de l'état on peut remarquer
que tous les états disposent de
mécanismes de péréquation financière
seulement tous les états ne met pas en
oeuvre la péréquation financière de la
même manière la méthode choisie dépend
finalement du degré d'autonomie que
l'état souhaite conférer à ces
collectivités territoriales la seconde
partie de ma thèse porte sur le constat
que la mise en oeuvre française la
péréquation financière du fait de son
extrême complexité du flou qui entoure
la définition constitution et de la
péréquation permet de faire de cet outil
non pas le support de la libre
administration mais l'instrument d'une
recentralisation de l'état l'intérêt de
ma thèse est tout d'abord de présenter
un inventaire complet des mécanismes de
péréquation financière en france
métropolitaine et dans les territoires
d'outre-mer par ailleurs j'ai adopté une
perspective résolument comparatiste et
examiner le fonctionnement pour établir
des comparaisons de système de
péréquation financière étrangers le
second rapport de ma thèse et l'apport
principal c'est de proposer une
conception de la péréquation financière
en phase avec le principe de libre
administration des collectivités
territoriales
en effet le contexte actuel de
raréfaction des ressources financières
locales rend aujourd'hui absolument
indispensable de concevoir un système de
péréquation respectueux de l'autonomie
financière locale